Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie, Marvel released the Marvels movie on digital
in a nice shiny
HD version of the X-Men Beast post-credits scene
there's a lot of things that they're setting up with it
as they finally start to bring back all the X-Men
and do new X-Men movies, particularly in Deadpool
three, in Avengers Secret Wars.
there were a bunch of questions
you guys were asking about why they use these
X-Men characters in the scene, specifically, like,
why Kelsey Grammer's version of Beast
when you could have put any X-Men characters
in this scene, Like you could have put Wolverine
in his yellow costume
from Deadpool three In this scene.
but it's all meant to be the beginning
of really big things.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we're supposed to get that Deadpool
three trailer at the Super Bowl next week.
Like we don't have to wait that long before
we actually get a ton of X-Men coming back.
But at the end of the movie, Monica Rambeau
uses her new photon powers in combination
with the power of both Ms..
Marvel's Bangles to close a rip in spacetime
between universes, stranding her in the X-Men universe.
She blacks out.
After closing the rift,
we only get a brief look at the space around
the other side of the rift too,
and it looks very different from Earth's space.
Notice The space around their version of Earth
is filled with red cloud looking nebula This is also
the X-Men version of Earth in frame two, because that's
where their battle was happening in the MCU universe.
Like Monica gets stuck in the X-Men Earth's orbit.
All this redness around
the space might have something to do
with how much more comicbook accurate
this universe is meant to be.
And they've just been through way more
cosmic events in Marvel history involving the X-Men.
Like the Phenix Saga,
Probably because the Fantastic Four exist
on this universe, a version of the Galactus saga.
Like pretty much every major cosmic event
that would cause
changes in Earth's galaxy that you could imagine.
also probably one to casual fans
watching the scene to be able to tell
when she crossed between universes Like this place.
She travels to is a completely different
X-Men universe.
You'd be surprised at how casual audiences get confused
at little details like this.
you can see some of the lights on earth.
The coloration of the earth is a little different
because of the reddish nebula surrounding it,
But otherwise it's meant to look
just like the MCU version of Earth.
Monica closes the rift, passes out,
then wakes up inside the basement of the mansion.
And it's based on the expansion
from pretty much all the X-Men movies.
That was kind of the joke of the Deadpool movies
that he was planning on is that he wasn't sure
which verse the X-Men
it was because they look so similar Generally,
though, it looks closer to the version of the expansion
in the original Bryan Singer X-Men movies.
finding out
her mother is binary from the comics in this universe
saved her, brought her back to Earth in a way.
More comic book, accurate version of Kelsey Grammer's
beast is examining her and researching the rift
between universes, talking about the multiverse
while trying to get more information out of Monica.
Like, let's see what's going on here.
Notice that her mother, Maria Rambeau, is wearing
both of Ms..
Marvel's Bangles in this universe.
In the movie,
they canonize the Bangles as sort of a combination
of the Kree Negabands and the quantum
bands from the comics.
I've talked about them in previous videos,
but some other changes
that Marvel made to them in the movies
that they didn't specifically state like.
It's kind of subtext in the movie.
they said that the original creator of the bands
is meant to be the first version of Quasar in the MCU.
There was a deleted scene at the beginning of the movie
that would have shown more of the backstory
behind the bands in this version of Quasar
that she digs up.
part of the idea is the darker
Ben finds the remains in this previous
version of Quasar
was also killed by the power of the Bangles.
The way that she was killed by the power of the Bangles
at the end of the movie.
like she met the same fate
as this original Quasar In the comics,
The quantum bands were created by the cosmic being Ian,
who's featured briefly during Thor, Love and Thunder.
He's one of the cosmic beings here,
but he represents time, life, cosmic awareness.
He gave the bands to the ancient Kree
empire in the comics, in the MCU.
They didn't take it this far.
They just said that this unnamed ancient Kree scientist
use them to become the first quasar
and use them to create all the jump points
around the universe.
James Gunn actually said that he created
the concept of jump points
in the first Guardians of the Galaxy movie
as a sort of quick travel system around the universe.
Like he needed a quick way
to get the Guardians of the Galaxy around in.
That was jump points.
they're not really a thing in the comics.
some in the movie.
This is why the power of the Bangles is tied to the
jump gates and why it's able to rip holes in spacetime.
and the reason
why they're called the quantum bands in the comics
is because they're powered by quantum energy
from the Quantum zone, The quantum realm,
essentially in the MCU,
they're sort of like Green Lantern rings.
the reason why they separated the bands in the MCU
and Ms..
Marvel isn't just wearing both of them
now is because they felt like they were too powerful,
too dangerous
to be left in the care of a normal teenage girl.
it'd be kind of like letting Spider-Man
keep half the Infinity Stones
in a sock in his bedroom drawer
recipe for disaster of cosmic proportions.
as you start zooming
in, enhancing around the scene, notice that big stars
talking to her about the multiverse in the MCU universe
she comes from.
They're careful not to give too much away,
but I think Marvel gives
you enough here
to figure out what this is all supposed to mean.
this version of Kelsey Grammer is BS
isn't the one from the main X-Men universe.
Like the original X-Men movies
themselves is a complete redesign of the character.
They're using motion capture
now instead of the physical beast suit
that Kelsey Grammer used to have pasted on to him
in the original X-Men movies.
he only appeared as his version of Beast
a couple of times, though X-Men, The Last Stand,
and then at the end of X-Men Days of Future Past,
after they change the timeline.
now that we have a nice
shiny HD version of this scene,
we can see way more what's going on in frame
and even though he's not wearing a shirt
under his lab coat, he's not totally naked or anything.
His pants are designed to look like
the classic X-Men suits
in the 1960s,
when he was on that first version of the team.
I think because Kevin Feige wanted this X-Men universe
to be a way,
way more comic book accurate version
in anticipation of Deadpool three.
When more of these characters
come back, like more accurate versions
of the original X-Men,
Fantastic Four actors coming back from those movies.
so even though you only see the cutoffs
below his lab coat, here he is wearing pants
and the reason why Maria Rambeau is on this X-Men team
in particular is because in the original comics,
Carol Danvers became the binary character
and according to Chris Claremont,
who created that version of the Captain
Marvel character, like he created binary,
he didn't create Captain Marvel At the time
she was supposed to replace the Phenix character
on the team who Marvel told him he couldn't use
in this particular arc of the X-Men comics.
And it was right after Rogue
basically sucked all of her power away.
Speaking of comic book accurate, they actually did
a version of this during X-Men, the animated series.
in the comics.
That's how Rogue gained the ability to fly.
She actually took the power from Captain Marvel
so she became binary,
then joined the X-Men team in this particular comic
and in this universe.
They're also saying that Maria Rambeau
was the one who had the Tesseract ax and it got powers
instead of Carol Danvers.
That's why she still looks young,
because her powers slow the aging,
kind of like the version that we saw in the A38
universe in Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness.
But it's not that same version.
that means that this X-Men universe
is not the A38 universe.
marie also has no idea who Monica Rambeau is
because Monica doesn't exist in this universe.
Like she never had a child
that named her Monica in the back
you can actually get a much better
look at Bea's monitor.
This is a picture of the trip in space
time to the MCU universe.
we get a slightly better look around the room too.
It's one of the many rooms of the original expansion
basement, like the blue doors that we saw
all over the base when Wolverine is running around
in the same area we visited the original Medical Bay
in the X-Men movies a couple of times,
but it didn't have the glass enclosure.
this is probably just meant to be
one of the other rooms, like the medical wing down
there is bigger than we saw in the original movies,
mostly for budgetary reasons,
like those original X-Men movies probably try to keep
the budget is under control as possible.
also one of the reasons
why Kevin Feige is using this version of the expansion,
like making everything
look so much like the original X-Men movies
just make more comic book accurate, shinier versions
because he actually got his start produced thing
on the Marvel movies in the original Bryan
Singer X-Men 2000 movie.
This is a picture of baby Kevin Feige working
with all the other people on the movie at the time.
B says the Charles Professor
X wants an update on Monica Rambeau.
What's going on with the rift between universes?
And it is meant to be Patrick Stewart's Professor X.
he also implied that he was coming back in future
Marvel movies recently.
He made it sound like it was going to be Deadpool three
because he was answering Deadpool questions
when he was talking about coming back.
But I also think that Kevin Feige is trying to get
a handful of these original X-Men actors
also to come back for secret wars.
But that won't happen till 2027 or 2028 at the rate
they're going right now.
There've been a couple of delays
and this gets to the other reason why Kevin Feige
brought back Kelsey Grammer as beast
instead of Nicholas Hoult version of Beast
or say, any other X-Men character,
because you could have used any team member
from the X-Men, like Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine could have shown up in his shiny
new comic book Accurate Yellow Suit here too.
And it would have worked.
this scene is meant to set up Deadpool three.
So it is possible
that Deadpool finds this Wolverine in this universe
but it's also because Kelsey Grammer is beast
was probably the best version of the character.
It never really got his due in the movies.
He showed up in X-Men The Last Stand.
Then they rebooted right into first class.
At the time, Kelsey
Grammer said that when they were premiering X-Men
The Last Stand,
he had signed a contract for multiple sequel movies.
And at the time he was confident that he was going
to be coming back for a bunch more movies as his beast.
he was really pumped up about it, too.
Like he sounded generally excited
about playing the Beast character,
like he loved it back in the day,
even though it was way more work, prosthetics.
He like it took way more time
to turn him into beast than it does now
and generally I think Kevin Feige agrees with this too,
and that's why he brought him
back, is because his depiction of beast
is much more accurate
to what he's supposed to feel like,
just generally his personality and because now
the technology is so good with motion capture
like this, the same technology that they used to do.
Mark Ruffalo's version of the Hulk
or even that She-Hulk character.
notice the way that when beast is talking
like you get have to slow the footage down.
You can see his cheeks move like his face muscles move
as he's emoting in a more lifelike way
than when he was wearing the beast suit.
In the original X-Men movies.
physically, he's also way, way larger,
which is more comic book accurate.
the other really good comparison
here would be X-Men, the Animated Series,
because we're getting X-Men 97 episodes
to that version of Beast.
Also a much more comic book accurate.
And this version is meant to look just like that.
Like you notice the way his hair looks, too.
Is much more comic book accurate.
so one of the other major reasons why
they brought beast back of all characters in this scene
was that they could use it
to actually test out their new technology
before they bring all the X-Men characters
back in Deadpool three in Secret Wars.
For example, it's way easier for them to do
Hugh Jackman's more comic book, Accurate Wolverine,
because you put him in the yellow suit
and you only need to do special effects
for, like his claws, maybe a little bit for his helmet.
beep is just a much better test
of how they can pull this stuff off
Marvel's done stuff like this a lot in the past.
Do They did the same thing with Mark
Ruffalo's Hulk before Avengers Endgame.
Like before we go whole hog,
like doing a bunch of scenes with him
as a smart version of We're going to test it out
in a scene like this.
but even though Deadpool might be finding
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine in this particular universe
and these versions of the X-Men
will probably come back in secret wars eventually,
I don't think that Monica Rambeau herself
will come back in Deadpool three,
or if she does, there might be some sort of follow up
in the Post-Credits scene
Because Deadpool three is meant to directly
set up Avengers secret wars, whatever.
Avengers five winds up being,
it might be a little bit different.
Deadpool three is all about setting up Battle world
in secret wars.
This X-Men Post-Credits
scene is meant to be connected to that stuff.
So we don't think Monica Rambeau herself will come back
until Secret Wars, but she will come back.
and there's a ton of other X-Men related questions
because so much of that is going to be happening
during Deadpool three.
We'll get that first trailer
in the next couple of weeks.
It will answer a lot of questions
about how Deadpool and Wolverine
will both destroy and save the Marvel multiverse.
we'll probably get a couple other teasers
before that, like Ryan Reynolds
and Hugh Jackman always dropped teasers in addition
to like the really big trailer.
So whatever they wind up releasing,
of course I'll do videos for
So be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss any of that.
Click here and here for those brand new Deadpool
three teasers that they just released.
There's a whole bunch of stuff that they just dropped.
So thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you guys in the next one!